Instructor: Strings
in ES6 come with four new
methods that are really handy,
help us write a little bit more
readable code, as well as reduce
our reliance on using RegExp for
certain things. Here I've
got this course. RFB, this
stands for React for Beginners.
Sometimes I have RFB1 which is
the starter package, 2 which is
the master package, 3 which is
the team package. I don't really
care too much about that in
certain cases, I just want to
know does it start with RFB, not
something like STPU, which is
Sublimed Text Power User or ES6,
which is this series. RFB
means React for Beginners. I
need to know, does the string
start with it? We can just take
the course, if it starts with
RFB, that's going to show me
true because obviously it does
start with it. If I did RFB
lowercase, it says, "false."
There is no way to make this
case insensitive. If you do need
case sensitivity you do need to
still use a RegExp. One other
thing that startsWith with will
do is it'll allow you to skip a
certain number of characters and
start looking at it. This
flight number here, I want to
see if it starts with AC. It's
false, because it starts with 20-.
Sometimes we have these SKU
numbers, when they start with a
bunch of junk and then it gets
to actually what we want.
What you can do is you can run
startsWith and then say pass 3,
and that says start after three
characters. That is then true,
because it ignores the first
three and then starts at AC and
checks against that. EndsWith
works fairly similar. Here is an
example where we have JZ on the
back, and I want to know if it's
a jazz flight. We can say flight
number.endsWith JZ -- J Zed,
depends if you're from Canada or
not. That will be true obviously,
because it ends with it.
There's another option that we
can pass endsWith, and I'm going
to use this account number
variable as an example here. In
Canada we have business numbers
that are nine digits long.
They're always nine digits long,
and that is your actual business
number. Then you have a tax
number, which is RT 0001, 0002.
You have RP 0001 for your first
employee, RP 0002 for your
second employee, etc. We have RC
for your corporate taxes. Often
you need to know, is this number
a tax number or is this number a
corporate tax number, or is this
a payroll number? That would be
if it's RC, or RP, or RT. I
need to check if this number,
ends with RT, and I want to
ignore this right here. What you
can do is you can tell the
account number to just take the
first X number of characters,
and ignore the rest. I'm
going to say account.endsWith RT.
Ends with, not width, RT. That's
false, but what I can tell it is
only take the first 11 numbers,
and that is then true.
Essentially you're just going to
take the first 11 numbers,
ignore the rest, and then see if
it ends in RT or whatever else
it is. Then next up we have
includes. Includes will just
check if that string is anywhere
in it. If I wanted to say, if my
flight number includes, anywhere,
if it includes the words AC,
that is true. Again, it is not
case sensitive so you cannot do
that. You have to know that.
Includes is anywhere in. It was
supposed to be called .contains,
but now it got changed to
includes because of some
conflicts with the MooTool
libraries and the way that they
modified the prototype. Next
up we have make, model and color
here. I'm going to show you
where that would be useful for
using .repeat. What does repeat
do? Repeat allows you to take a
string, like a snake, and repeat
it. "Get my snake back," repeat
it like 10 times. That'll
give you 10 snakes or 1,000
snakes, or however many snakes
you would like. You can just
call .repeat and it's going to
repeat that string over and over
and over again. Where is that
useful? Sometimes we have some
words here. I'm going to take
BMW X5 in royal blue, and if I
wanted to display them maybe in
a terminal or something, but I
want to right align them. How
would that work? I'd have to
just put a whole bunch of
padding in, depending on how
long this was and how much space
will go in here. That is
what is called a left pad
function, and you can use .
repeat to code a nice little
left pad function. Let's do this,
function, leftPad. That will
take in the string that we want
to pad and the length that we
wish to have it. I'm going to
set that to a default of 20
characters. Inside of here,
we can return. We're just going
to return a string which I'm
just going to start with a
little arrow, just to show us
where we are, and we need to
then pad it with however many
characters we need. We'll take a
space and repeat however many.
How many do we need? We take the
length minus string.length. If
it's 3, it's going to give us 17
spaces that have been repeated,
and them we just tack on the
string there. Now I've got this
nice little leftPad function.
I can take make, model, and
color, put them in here. It's
going to console.log each one of
them out. Console.log leftPad
model. I'm going to leave out
the length because we're going
to default it to 20, and it
should just pass in the make,
model, and color. There we go.
See how all these are perfectly
left aligned? BMW X5 in royal
blue, whereas all of this is
however much padding we actually
need. That's a nice little use
for repeat. Another little
funny one that you can do is, we
can take an ES6 template string,
and inside of that let's do a
statement where we take a...what
we do we want to multiply?
Dancing lady, string of dancing
lady, times five. What
happens when you take a string
and multiply it by a number? You
get a Nan. Some of you might
have a Nan, yourself. Let's call
repeat on that 10 times, and
then tack on Batman. What's
that going to give us? Nan Nan
Nan Nan Nan Nan Nan Nan Batman.
Pretty funny. I didn't make that
up. I saw it online somewhere,
but I thought it was pretty cool
because what's happening here,
you're giving yourself
essentially a string of Nan,
repeat it 10 times, and then
you're tacking on Batman on to
the end. Those are some four
new ones. Put them in your back
pocket, and hopefully enjoy that.
Thanks.